welcome to this video this is a new part
of chess Giants and this son v was
featuring
yeah two great players one is them with
the white pieces marks over the Dutch
world champion in the 30s on be playing
against Paul Karason at the time it was
played in 1940 in a match between the
two
we've already had lost the title back to
Anakin and a coin I have a problem with
his name yeah let's have a look at this
game Paul Karason playing like probably
one of the greatest players who never
became world champion and in this game
we see Kara's really and in yeah with
with the some full power playing playing
very powerful chance let's see what
happens in the game we have a quite
opening actually the Queen's Indian
defense note that here in the 1940s this
was not yet very well established
opening you know only like 15 years
before in the days of kappa blanka
playing alekan they had played the
Queens gambit declined all the time and
these concepts the nimzo-indian xenian
were relatively new but we see that in
this game relatively modern line was
played something that is still very much
normal nowadays um yeah 94 by Kerris he
puts his knight in the center and yeah
just by occupying eform he makes sure
that white is not advancing this pawn
yeah nowadays the main line is probably
Bishop d2 when this position is reached
after which black him yeah has so
various IDs Bishop f6 or f5 those kind
of moves Queen c2 however was played by
Weaver still one of the main moves of
course yeah black now captured Queen
takes yeah the next move by Cara's is
much plate nowadays it's probably a
little bit less accurate than the
alternatives what black normally is
doing here is in modern times he's
playing f5 or c5 f5 typically intends to
play Bishop f6 putting some pressure on
the center maybe even 96 later on with a
little bit less aggressive as c5 you
know which sometimes after a trade here
can lead to head Shakhtar position we're
seeing demonstrated what caris is
playing a sound different he played d6
first it's not clear that you need this
move for structures with their five and
wonder the problem with it is that after
Queen c2 played by over there is this
threat Knight g5 threatening made on age
7 and threatening here the unprotected
Bishop black plates f5 and necessary
move otherwise this Knight g5 was
hitting him or just a form taking the
center and the reason why this is very
slightly inaccurate is that in this f5
structures it's not clear that you want
t6 being played as it's a really weakens
this square nothing theta but a little
bit inaccurate 91 now was played instead
there also was d5 and moved that I guess
I would affirm heavily considered in
this position trying to yeah for c5 it's
clear that this is really bad him here
here n t5 yeah so not a good idea
d5 and now with moves like Evo white can
try to get control over those slight
squares
um maybe promising white a slight edge
nothing great but a little bit of
something yeah in the game over plate 91
which was also came and now Queen c8 was
played maybe taking was simpler but it's
it's not a big deal
efore was played and 97 by black yeah we
see that white has build up a very nice
Center the question is is it yeah is it
a big advantage for white with the
center it seems that despite these six
not being maybe super accurate the whole
thing is still fairly solid for black
white has no wrote to to a cleared share
or something however what becomes
apparent quite quickly is that the move
now played by white by the former world
champion it's not the most testing one
it seems that why definitely should take
on f5 and proceed from there for example
after the capture like takes and then d5
this is something that intense a
maneuver like that going to e6 in the
long run probably even that it's not
super great for white because c6 we
quickly open up the position in a
situation where wide it's not so well
developed this is actually the reason
why white is not really yeah on the way
to a huge edge because of his somewhat
lagging development but this is what he
should do he played in the game the move
d5 and this is based probably on some
misjudgment of the next couple of moves
black took on e4
that's clear twin takes d4
yeah the other moves don't really help I
mean if if he takes on e6 then just
Knight c5 which is clearly leading
nowhere with the e4 pawn all of a sudden
perfectly protected and this is lost if
he takes with the bishop there is Knight
f6 very nice move protecting the h7 pawn
there is nothing going on here and what
can also of course not take here because
this is simply blundered then
so now the pressure becomes very serious
on the center yeah in comparison taking
with the queenís is really the better
this was played by over
yeah and now night see five and we see
that this is already quite quite
comfortable yeah black gets this get
this important tempo in and yeah
definitely should have a decent position
yeah why is black having a good position
yeah if you look at this white again
needs to move the Queen
he went to e tune but I guess I guess
okay and after that I mean the other
squares are not really much better like
Queen c2 and then Bishop f6 and we see
that black iam has really gained a lot
in terms of activity this is a great
Bishop now there is still pressure here
and Wyatt has not yet completed its
development it's not very well
coordinated it's absolutely necessary
now for what to be precise yeah if you
make one or two more mistakes it it will
be a very very problematic it seems that
here the best defense would have been to
simply take on e6 just take down
basically going for simplifications what
we probably happen is black will take
Knight takes 96 and this is quite
obviously okay for black yeah 94 is a
good threat should be parried with
Bishop III and the sources at the time
in the common spire Karason gala again
are not at the time there was a bit a
little bit young at the time but when he
did come true later they said that this
is about equal yeah I think maybe if we
look at Queen b7 rupee aid coming black
is slightly more comfortable based on
his more active pieces this is the
knight is a little bit sorry
so black has a slight edge which
probably makes sense due to white having
lost so much time in the in the Moose
before however still this is what he
should have done
he played Bishop h3 yes still being
ambitious yeah with this diagonal yeah
like went through p8 quite clear
covering on e6 and also this is
introducing a threat like really intends
to take despite the pin because the
Queen only to is also hanging completely
and so white cannot play any slow
muthiya he went Bishop e3
yeah covering the Queen in a way
blocking the e-file and now the next
part of the game from here I mean up to
now caris has just played very normal
moves in a way next part of the game is
conducted very very powerfully played
Queen d8 looks like nothing special but
it has a great idea right now captured
on c5 certainly intending to just win
the pawn but black has a great
intermediate move I'm sorry if this was
but a little bit quick he can take on d5
this is very strong an intermediate move
on with an attack on the Queen
if white now retreats to e3 then there
is d4 coming in fact this is what white
um should have done absolutely the only
way to to still maintain a playable
position if in the game you played
Bishop e6 the move that I already had
put on the board a little bit
prematurely we should look at Bishop e3
though it should be three what happens
after that
just e4 of course we get the piece back
after Bishop g2 takes takes takes Knight
takes yeah now black has this
opportunity to play Bishop deform which
it should take and now we get to this
position where black of course has
a more comfortable game this is just
very ugly weakness but this is something
that white should hold yeah it is it's
not fun yeah
really not the kind of position where
you yeah I know that you have a long
long day of suffering ahead of you if
you play this against a player like with
under Sun if you want some somebody from
the 70s 80s 90s or modern day cars and
yeah this is like the ultimate horror
but still you're not losing right away
on I in danger to danger of getting
beaten down like it happened in the game
yeah in the game if we go back here we
will play to check on it six okay King
edge eight and now you went rook t1
mmm-hmm okay this looking that bad right
why look t1 by the way if you take
you're running into this pin yeah the
Moose don't really make sense right so
look t1 this is this is okay and what
did Karis play now he took on c5 b takes
e5 was also very interesting but this is
this is okay this is a good move and now
Knight G to this is what what this is an
uber said I he wants to use the night
and maybe gain control over d5
if you don't play 92 course there was an
alternative like this then black simply
has a bishop deform activating this
Bishop with with huge effect it's a very
very nice position of the bishop much
better than this night for example and
of course this is still very weak pawn
yeah he went as mentioned he went Luke
too
keep one takes and then not this but 92
yeah after 92 Karis now played the only
yeah
mistake in in the game he went with
deform
he pushed the pawn um here it is some
with the modern I are pretty clear that
the move Bishop deformed was even
stronger and it's a it's fairly simple
once here once you see it it's this is
just a fantastic piece and there is no
tactic way technical way that wide now
can can stay up some trouble you just
have this dominating bishop on deform in
the game after deform this Bishop is not
really active and one problem might be
that there are scenarios where black
retains an extra pawn if we do account
black as a pawn up here when he retains
the pawn but where white is setting up a
blockade with the best possible move now
this is a scenario that might happen but
it wasn't played by we were played to f4
now trying to support the bishop here
and for oops come on f1 intending to
play a 5 yet the best defense here what
rook F to e1 centralizing this and
intending to play Queen age 5 and night
f4 activating and there are scenarios
where it will be very very difficult to
win for example if black plays Bishop c8
using this pin after Queen g4 and all
those traits if we try a very simple
approach then in a position like that
covering here white intends to play
Knight a 1 to D 3 and from there it
would be very difficult to win you have
the extra pawn but well everything's on
dark squares and this bishop is not
doing much besides looking at his own
part so this is a technically difficult
task black has of course serious winning
chances still
but it's it's tough it's tough not easy
to win bishop deform was a much cleaner
solution however this is one of those
cases where deform while not being
objectively best leads to a fantastic
continuation of the game so we would
have been robbed of a fantastic yeah end
of the struggle not this was played but
their form yeah and now in this position
Karis played a fantastic concept
brilliant and yeah not sure if I should
give this to you as a as an as an
exercise but yeah maybe maybe you can
can look for a way for black now to to
completely activate all his forces black
has a way now to activate tremendously
and it is based on the fact that f4 has
one serious drawback in weakens the King
yeah maybe you can look here what is the
best move for black here ok I'm going to
going to put it on the board now carries
now played the excellent move d3 yeah
giving up a pawn with a great point and
it only really makes complete sense with
the next move because after Luke takes
if you found d3 I'm not sure I mean not
sure if your idea was to play Bishop d4
or actually what what care is played
Bishop before is not bad by the way it
keeps an edge but the most forceful and
elegant move is of course the Queen
sacrifice Cara's really sacrificed his
Queen iam very nice therefore this rook
why it took check King f2 yeah look I
have to look f2 looks a bit weird like a
self pin but King age one rook is six
intending to play rook e8 and then
rookie 2 was not much not much better
note that this is like the most
brilliant bishops you can imagine
yes fantastic fantastic situation and
yeah whoever played rukka f2 it's
probably the relatively best best
defense and then rupees six this was the
position that Karis had in mind when he
played d3 with the subsequent C Queen
sacrifice yeah there are really made
threats near yeah like if if you give
black to moves in a row something like
this and this is very close to happening
or rookie to of course very very strong
yeah why played King to f1 getting out
of the pin and now rupee aid was played
it was also possible to take on f2
probably also winning but it's difficult
in this position really to to evaluate
if you want to take on f2 immediately
because this Bishop is just so great in
comparison to this sorry rook so I mean
it's a matter of concrete lines of
course but rook a e8 it seems also from
a purely analytical point of view is
just as good as Bishop takes f2 yeah
white now played f5 which is not the
toughest defense maybe but I think white
is probably in a hopeless state anyway
um when this was analyzed years ago they
thought that Luke d2 or oopsie two moves
of the second rank should give white
better chances of survival may be true
but the main problem is that this is
coming with just just to show the IDM
here and then Bishop f5 this is
switching over to this diagonal setting
up this pin and the King is really in an
almost a mating net yeah it's very very
tough to find the defense here I think
ultimately this will still lose but
maybe it was yeah hanging on a little
bit longer but you cannot blame over for
playing at five I mean it's just like
impossible to defend practically any way
and maybe even in a theoretical sense
are not possible Ruki 5 and f6s was the
idea here trying to get some sort of
activity
yeah like took and rookie - there's
really not much that white could do him
if he takes on f6
there's rookie - and this is a direct
made threat so not not something that
you can defend yeah as mentioned Brooke
group t2 was played now Bishop c8 the
idea that we had seen before the bishop
switches diagonals for the final part of
the attack with the bishop coming to h3
there is basically a dual threat
Lukie one mate when the bishop is there
and rookie - and it's not possible to
defend both white right Knight f4 Ruby 3
Queen to be won back look a three Queen
King g2 all this is is fast yeah it here
if you want you can look at this
position for a little bit and try to now
calculate the final moves of this game
it is not very difficult but so yeah
very beautiful very beautiful finish
yeah
caris now took on f4 very nice
sacrificing the exchange so that for the
moment he only has one bishop for the
Queen yeah it's very nice but the
bishops are so dominating after Luke g8
check we see that the King is in a
crossfire and we have the rook this
bishop and this bishop on this diagonal
or this diagonal yeah and White has no
way out if he goes here we have this
check and this is a medium can only
interpose some stuff
but ultimately we'll get checkmated king
f1 hmm that's not happening so you only
have king of free the game move and then
simply Bishop g4 check is the final
stroke if white goes to the G file then
at least this is winning maybe there's a
mate but it will be enough and after
Bishop g4 with a resigned King e-form
rupee a check King d5 is the fourth
continuation bishop check a Queenie form
Bishop before mate
very funny mate with those bishops and
the rook yeah a very nice game showing
that carries water a brilliant brilliant
attacking player when given the chance
in dynamic position he was was really
really an outstandingly good so if we do
a quick recap of the whole thing what
happened here we had a fourth time
modern opening
yeah like the Queen's Indian was not
something that they were having huge
experience and at the time with d5 it
shows a bit because this is giving away
any hope for a white advantage
caris reacts well he took on e4 and now
he gains number of Tempe for his
position here after Bishop age 3 we see
that white drifts into trouble and after
this Bishop b3 was the last opportunity
to probably keep him yeah i defendable
position I guess here it shows that the
defensive technique at the times at the
time simply it's not so much comparable
to nowadays where it I guess will be
pretty apparent to most players that you
need to suffer in this position and you
shouldn't go for that which puts you in
in a really precarious situation on the
ephah
however if white would have avoided the
mistake F form rook F e1 still would
have given plenty of fighting chances
after f4 karasek the chance to really
yeah unleash the power of his bishops
and he went on to win a great attacking
game where he has a fantastic
compensation in form of Bishop and rook
against the Queen
very well coordinated Bishop and rook
very often can compensate for the Queen
er this is one of those cases where
those two bishops are just so great that
the White Queen has has really very
little to do in this position I hope you
enjoyed this game it was a very nice
attacking effort by the great player
Paul Karras thanks for watching